the conference is for european tour dj
t shirt vision of what we went off the
moment and social justice between
generations we cannot replace the lost
time the time that the pandemic
has stolen from the youth but
we can do something fairer and
better for them and with them  build we
have to act now and young people
have to play a central
role
in this change fundamental things have to change
so that the next generation can
continue to have nature around them we have
to change so that our grandchildren can
still experience spring summer autumn and winter
and that's why i believe that  we
should use this conference to have a real
and structured dialogue between the
generations about how we
can preserve
livelihoods lay sympathy the feelings the brothers
pandemic in the end
the teachers
[applause]